[Music]
i'm so enchanted
by this system but the idea of treating
it is not really very serious seems to
me unthinkable
of course you have to think that
it's like a hypnotist working on
somebody and saying
you are not going to remember any of
this conversation
after you come to
and so he's put the suggestion into you
that you forget the whole thing
so in the same way the suggestion has
been put in to all of us
that these rules that we have learned
are sacrosanct and that we
they don't say you will not be able to
think otherwise
they say they are true they are the
truth
you see and that is the same function as
the hypnotic suggestion
put into us ever since we were receptive
children
[Music]
so naturally it's all part of the
conspiracy
which we are playing on ourselves we
can't blame our parents for this
because their parents played it on them
and they bought it and don't forget the
time goes backwards
you see you can't blame this on the past
because now in the present you are
creating the value
the values of the past and you are
buying them all along
see so there's no no out on this
you see in a way psychoanalytically one
is given an out
by saying well the parents didn't bring
up their children properly
and american people are consumed with
guilt about the way they
they bring up their children
we must abandon completely the notion
of blaming the past for any kind of
situation we're in
and reverse our thinking and see that
the past always flows back from the
presence
that now is the creative point
of life and so you see
uh it's like the idea of forgiving
somebody
uh you change the meaning of the past by
doing that
it's like also the when you watch the
flow of music
the melody as it is
expressed
is changed
by notes that come later
just as the meaning of a sentence
especially say take german
or latin whether it's the convention of
placing a verb at the end of a sentence
you wait in other words till later to
find out what the sentence means
according to our way of feeling it
so it is also in our language if i say i
love you
you don't know when i've said i
what i is doing
i could say i hate you
so we don't know until later so
in other words the word love or the word
hate changes
the function of the word i
and then i was going to say i love
flowers no but i love you you see and so
the word later
changes the meaning of those that go
before
the present is always changing the past
so when you get the idea in your mind
that the point of view i'm talking about
is very difficult indeed to acquire
that idea
is one you are putting there
to stop yourself seeing the other point
of view
and above all you must not take that
seriously
it is simply a method of postponing
seeing the point now
so you have to see it now or never
because
there is only now if you say well
tomorrow
the next day maybe in another dozen
lifetimes
i'll be ready that means simply and
solely
i don't want to be bothered with it now
i'm even not interested in it now so
i've got an excuse for putting it off
which is fine that's perfectly okay
you can put it off there is no reason
there is no compulsion
why you should come out of this illusion
that's why oriental people do not
tend in the same way as westerners to be
missionaries
and saying it's very urgent that you be
saved
it isn't unless you say so
i mean unless you are so disturbed by
the suffering and the problem of
suffering that you've got to find
some sort of escape
but if you don't want to you can still
it's okay there's lots of time
and maybe you'll see through it when you
die
at least in the moment of death you will
see that it was
all a fake
so don't be scared
about the idea of the difficulty of it
that's a red herring and it's quite
irrelevant and i don't think that
teachers should talk quite so much about
this as they do
and saying oh this is going to take a
long long time and a lot of practice in
many years
maybe it will maybe it won't
but that's beside the point
because it distracts it's like telling
somebody that this is a very difficult
book to read
and it requires immense powers of
concentration well that immediately
kills your interest in it
instead of if i would say well now this
is the most extraordinary book
this is so fascinating i've been working
on it for years
and every time i i just get so involved
i can't drop the thing
i mean that's a far more encouraging
attitude to a student
than uh well it's going to be very
difficult except for very very
self-hating students who somehow
perversely enjoy suffering through it
i suppose that's a of course the way too
but
all right now if we can
see the first part which is that the ego
is purely fictitious
that it is a symbol or image of oneself
plus a sensation of muscular strain
occasioned by trying to make this symbol
an effective agent
to control emotion
to concentrate to direct the nervous
operations of the organism
[Music]
then immediately it is clear that
what we have called ourselves what we
have thought of as ourselves
isn't able to do anything at all there
follows
this kind of silence
in which there is nothing to do except
watch what happens
[Music]
but what is happening is watching itself
there is nobody apart from it watching
it
and so we get into the state of
meditation
[Music]
so then the next problem that arises is
well what about all the other illusions
although they are somehow integrated and
centered upon the illusion of ego
nevertheless the whole value system
of what is important
what is not important what is good what
is bad what is pleasant what is painful
has to be called in question
not in order to destroy the whole value
system
but in order to see it for what it is
and that's where we will object and say
well surely that's a colossally
difficult task because
we are so long habituated to it and we
have been taught to believe that the
longer we have been habituated to
something
the more difficult it is to change it
and that is true if you believe it and
if you don't it isn't
so that's why it's always emphasized at
any rate in zen
that when anything is to be done it
should be done immediately
without thinking it over in advance act
at once
and you'll find that characteristic of
people trained in zen they always act
immediately
they don't uh say well um
well when should we do this sort of
thing they just do it
because that doesn't build up it gives
no time for the building up of all this
reflection of
well i've done this way for a long time
and i really feel kind of
draggy about uh doing it another way
it's like some people eat the same thing
every day the idea of suddenly eating
something else seems
absolutely weird
i remember when i used to have lunch in
london and the city of london
i used to go to their rather fancy
sandwich bar
and there was a very square young man in
a derby hat
who ordered exactly the same lunch every
day
fantastic
and so it came that the man who served
the bar the moment he saw him coming in
at the door he had it there
and he would have had a real qualm if
somebody had suggested that instead of
having a beef sandwich he should have a
smoked salmon
[Music]
now then we get to this what we are
aware of
is a complex of vibrations
and we have been conditioned to call
them
graduatingly good bad pleasant painful
whereas as a matter of fact they are
nothing but vibrations
and if you look at any one of them by
itself
you won't know where it is
[Music]
that is to say if you only know red
you can't see that it's red you can only
know that this is red by contrast
with yellow and green and blue and
violet
so you don't know that the sound is loud
unless you know soft sounds
or you don't know that it's soft unless
you know loud
and it is that comparison
which gives us the feeling of the
spectrum
as being varied otherwise we wouldn't
know
for example when you watch television
you are actually seeing a single
moving point moving
over the screen but it goes so fast
that you see it in all these different
places having different values of light
but let us supposing there was someone
whose retina was not retentive in this
way
he would look at the screen and see the
moving point of light and say to human
beings i don't see what you see in this
now can we
therefore get back not only to the
situation
where we see that the ego
is a mere construct
but also where we see that all the
values
we put on the vibrations are arbitrary
and that we get to a position where we
see the vibrations simply as the
vibrations
and we would say that well surely all
this is nonsense
which is correct
the universe i mean is a kind of uh
badoudi
um going on in this fantastic way
this is why music
can be used as a meditative technique
because a lot of music is in this is
nonsense
it doesn't mean anything
but it can be very interesting
so can you get back again to
recollecting from
childhood your pleasure
in events
that from your present point of view you
would call entirely meaningless
that you could
listen to a sound like twanging metal
and it goes
boing boing boing
boing and that's fascinating
boring
it's just boring and that's that's all
it is
see now if you can really get with boy
[Music]
you can see the whole universe in boeing
[Music]
really because
every vibration that's possible implies
all the others
[Music]
and so likewise with a candle flame with
a reflection
with grain and wood anything
can from this child point of view
be completely fascinating not because it
means anything
but just for what it is that it is
shaped
[Music]
so
you